je m'appelle clément luzerne je suis
administrateur à la commission des
affaires sociales depuis quatre ans
un administrateur en commission
accompagne le rapporteur d'un projet
doivent d'une proposition doit
c'est-à-dire le sénateur qui à
l'intérieur de la commission est désigné
par ses collègues pour instruire un
projet de loi et venait des auditions
proposer des modifications au texte lors
de l'examen du projet de loi sur la
protection des enfants le rapporteur a
souhaité présenter à ses collègues un
amendement pour que l'hébergement des
enfants protégés à la dans des hôtels
soit totalement interdite alors que la
loi prévoyait des dérogations pour que
démineurs puissent être accueillis à
l'hôtel
avec mon collègue administrateurs qui
travaillaient sur le texte nous avons
donc dû préparer un projet d'amendement
qui encadraient juridiquement la façon
dont on pouvait interdire totalement
l'hébergement de mineurs à l'hôtel on
est là aussi pour les aider à
communiquer auprès de leurs collègues et
du grand public sur les orientations que
les rapporteurs et les points qui ont
été adoptées ou actée par le sénat la
semaine prochaine ya la proposition de
loi sur le monde combattant qui est
examiné en deuxième lecture par la
commission des affaires sociales et on
prépare un document synthétique qui va
expliquer pour les sénateurs et pour le
grand public le contenu de la
proposition de loi
il faut aussi aimer travailler en équipe
à la fois avec des élus et avec ses
collègues ou nous sommes parfois
plusieurs à travailler sur une même
mission d'information ou sur un terrain
texte de loi par ailleurs on est amené à
faire des déplacements à l'extérieur qui
permettent aux sénateurs d'aller se
rendre compte sur place de comment se
déploie une politique publique très
enrichissant de vivre ça au quotidien et
de contribuer à notre niveau à
l'élaboration des projets de loi des
réformes qui font l'actualité d'une api
[Musique]